hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge super die sie germany sind
heute wieder zurück in der küche es ist
herbst es wird kälter draußen es ist
super zeit
ich liebe sie ich hoffe euch geht es
genauso und wir kochen heute eine
möhrensuppe möhrensuppe haben wir den
ganz unterschiedlichen art und weisen
kochen
ich koche sie manchmal mit kokosmilch
und irgendwann also etwas schärfer es
gibt aber auch die mildere version mit
sahne und petersilie
ich glaube das machen wir heute dass es
auch eher typisch deutsch
aber ich mache es immer ganz frei
schnauze was ich gerade da habe
los geht's
[Musik]
das gute daran eine suppe zu kochen ist
dass man nicht viel braucht und ist sehr
einfach ist
also ich brauche nur einen großen
kochtopf das hat gequietscht dann einen
pfannenwender eine suppenkelle wenn die
suppe später fertig ist ein gutes
schneidemesser das war es auch schon von
den sachen mit denen wir kochen dann die
zutaten möhren ganz viele möhren
ich habe zwei drei kartoffeln die binden
die suppe schön wir haben es etwas
cremiger muss man natürlich nicht machen
dann etwas butter zum anbraten
gemüsebrühe
damit wird dass die angebrachten möhren
und kartoffeln werden damit abgelöscht
dann sahne später um die suppe cremig zu
machen braucht man auch nicht unbedingt
kann man auch mit kokosmilch machen wenn
man es begann machen möchte oder mit
soja sahne mag ich auch sehr gerne
ich hatte jetzt nur normales anita daher
normale sonne dann haben wir pfeffer
salz petersilie und knoblauch
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich und
wahrscheinlich steht es jetzt schon in
den kommentaren wo sind die zwiebeln ich
weiß zwiebeln in einer suppe sind immer
gut leider bin ich allergisch und kann
sie nicht essen
dementsprechend gibt es bei mir nur
knoblauch in der suppe aber gott sei
dank kann ich den essen
oops ich habe tatsächlich das
allerwichtigste verhelfen nämlich dem
pürierstab sonst wird es nämlich
hinterher keine suppe uns wird zum
eintopf und einstellen deshalb brauchen
wir auch noch falls ihr euch jetzt
übrigens fragt warum heißt es eigentlich
die möhre und das messer dann schaut
doch mal was sie gern vorbei hier oben
und probiert unsere gender trainer aus
da könnt ihr die artikel zu den 2000
wichtigsten deutschen lernen ok jetzt
geht's los
juhu die beste aufgabe darin ist
tatsächlich alle möhren schälen und die
kartoffeln nicht wahr der leute geben
die amazon stehen ich finde das dauert
ewig dementsprechend und das so gemacht
das müssen wir jetzt alles leider einmal
vorspielen
dort nämlich ist im moment weiter geht's
herr waldie karotten gestellt so viel
arbeit macht dann doch nicht jetzt
werden die kartoffeln geschält
das finde ich noch schlimmer christen
bilden zu sehen weil nirgends sehen ist
irgendwie ja total einfach getroffen
muss man immer so viel druck anwenden
und irgendwie kartoffelschälen das ist
jetzt wirklich nicht meine
lieblingsaufgabe aber gibt es für viele
das gerne macht könnte ja auch mal in
die kommentare schreiben wert steht
gerne kartoffeln
vielleicht gibt's ja möchte das gerne so
jetzt können wir mit dem kochen loslegen
erstmal streichhölzer um den helfern zu
stellen
los geht's gas und gott topf auf die
flamme
dann kommt die butter im topf und jetzt
schneiden wir alles und ab in den
kochtopf liebe am morgen machen ist
anders direkten eingang
sie ist es hier gleich noch ein küchen-
und vergibt keine unfälle bitte mach mal
vielleicht jetzt geklagt nachdem rühren
anbraten
aber natürlich ist auch mit olivenöl
machen
ich mach das jetzt mit butter ein
bisschen format namens wichtig knoblauch
so weitergeht jetzt haben wir die möhren
und die kartoffeln angebrachten in der
butter mit knoblauch und jetzt werden
wir das ganze mit brühe ablöschen habe
hier gemüsebrühe
das dürfte genug sein es vielleicht
sogar schon etwas zu viel
ich mache das immer so dass das gemüse
wenn die suppe kommt zumindest leicht
bedeckt ist vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
und jetzt müssen wir warten jetzt kochen
wir erstmal die möhren und die
kartoffeln wahrscheinlich so circa 20
minuten vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
weil ich sie sehr klein geschnitten habe
so wir haben das ganze jetzt 20 minuten
kochen lassen
jetzt geht es weiter mit diesem part den
ich eben vergessen habe jetzt wird das
ganze für ihn noch am kochen macht die
flamme mal ganz klein
[Musik]
vielleicht sollte ich erst die sahne
zufügen
das ding ist wir haben gar nicht so viel
suppe es gibt also nur so viel platz und
der will starb kommt nicht richtig unter
das wasser deswegen spricht alles für
ihren mann nicht alles komplett weil ich
mag das nimmt es gerne wenn danach
stückchen von dem höheren drin sind und
dass mich so komplett durch kuriert ist
aber das kann man natürlich nach
belieben machen wir jetzt mal kurz pause
und füge erste sahne nicht so weil es
tatsächlich nicht so viel platz weg zum
tor dementsprechend machen jetzt einmal
die dame rein so erst mal so viel
dann haben wir schon mal mehr
flüssigkeit ja ja ja
so jetzt einmal abschmecken und dann
kann man schauen wie viel noch von den
gewürzen reinkommt dann machen wir das
jetzt einmal schmeckt na gut nicht
schlecht daher machen wir ein fass auf
jeden fall noch mal ein bisschen salz
ein bisschen knoblauch und petersilie
jetzt kommt auch endlich die suppenkelle
zum einsatz
dann schauen wir gleich nochmal ab ist
das schon ist so jetzt testen wir aber
vorher noch ein bisschen brot zum wippen
dazu dass poste ich jetzt nach das gute
daran dass wir koch episoden machen wo
wir kochen und euch deutsch beibringen
ist das immer was zu essen gibt der
letzte test liegt tatsächlich anders aus
hat sich die sonst mache wie ich schon
gesagt habe suppen sind von mir immer
ein spontanes das wird alles zusammen
geschmissen
es gibt kein wirkliches rezept ich mache
es immer nach laune und so schmeckt das
dementsprechend dann auch noch schmeckt
sehr lecker
anders als die sonne fahren würde
aber der interlink ist gut wir sind
fertig das ist das fertige produkt hat
dass sie jetzt gleich nicht rausfliegt
ich hoffe euch jetzt gefallen schreibt
uns mal die kommentare ob hier auch so
gerne suppe lügt und die auch bei euch
im herbst sehr beliebt sind und dann ich
hab schon zu beginn der episode gesagt
schaut mal bei sieht lang vorbei
probiert ihn der trainer aus und
trainiert die artikel
bis bald
[Musik]
er ist noch so heiß spritzt